that's some great dialogue they would
have been even better if he had to use
one of those this is going to be fun you
just know it when how it should have
ended has put together one who for a
heavily debated film star wars the rise
of Skywalker I can't wait to check this
out buddy buddy it's gonna be a
feature-length episode you guys haven't
seen her non-spoiler review for Star
Wars arises Skywalker there's a little
opening sketch there and we did a
spoiler talk going over all the problems
we have with the film overall I'm not
like a 60% with this movie I'll say that
I had a lot of issues with it and
there's also things I liked about it so
the non spoiler was pretty much
everything we liked 10 spoilers over
them I'm more like a 50/50 yep I don't
wanna think about this anymore
let's just watch how it should have
ended hey guys this episode is brought
to you by and we said nay no we said
give us until the new year
that's right yeah slight renditions and
they don't get copyright
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
- I cool you my
the light of the final order will soon
be ready it will be yours do as I
already have everything it's a pretty
leader duh but I will give you new
things they didn't beneath the ice room
complete with so scary we also have
detonators is that is that enough
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
sorry about that
[Music]
little minute he's out there with rain
you got a blaster do something about it
all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
taking one last look hey doctor is you
goodness of course not you I hardly know
you
and most of the time you'll route to me
if I weren't such a good companion I
would delete that stupid sick
translation right out of my memory banks
out of spite
yes you know what let's see how you like
it you see how far you get without me I
am c-3po human-cyborg relations
pieces
an assault team is landed on our home
jam the speeders they aren't using
speeders sir they're using space horses
really
[Laughter]
hold on you can use the force and hold
the lightsaber after your dad yes why
you are coming with me okay
[Music]
rude by Adrian you don't just get to
show up with the lock they can take back
what you already lost oh I'm afraid I
can if you strike me down my spirit will
be passed on into you oh I'm not going
to strike again
[Music]
nag me to death
from beyond degrees and a bunch of
ghosts I'm using the force to grab
objects anywhere in the universe I
suppose next you're going to tell me
that I can use the Force to heal wounds
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there touch someone Hayes take me up
when they could be taking him now
[Music]
yeah yeah chosen one
well that was anticlimactic foolish
should have died before
I learned it by watching you that's my
boy how interesting I would have liked
to see them it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
who are you I'm right right whoo revenge
of exploding yourself with like new
favorite charity sure you know my spirit
is now running with my granddaughter
everyone get out watching and thank you
again to Nord VPN for making this
episode you're welcome any what to
protect your data from the dark side
then a VPN is important oversimplify it
they basically shield your data on the
Internet I mean it was morally right
about promoting what VPN is as always
wonderfully edited a wonderfully
composed we animated hilarious these
guys have been so consistent for so many
years Thank You team for putting this
together and once again on top of being
hilarious you've also made some great
points I actually haven't heard that
point that suggestion or idea that you
bring up in the opening scroll of they
should have teased Emperor Palpatine at
the end of the last Jedi because that
actually would have blown my mind
thinking about it in the context of
watching the last Jedi I remember a
calming complaint with the way the last
Jedi wrapped up amongst all the
complaints work what are we supposed to
look forward to with the next one what
what exactly is it that we're supposed
to
wrap some things up but what are we
looking forward to exactly and if they
had teased that at the end I think we
all would have been very much in like
heavy anticipation for a couple years
ooh what's this the wrong gonna be how
is he back that would have really
enhanced the anticipation experience and
maybe done some numbers for Reza
Skywalker a little bit more because I I
did listen to that whole Robert Myer
Burnett leaking the Colin Trevorrow
scripted thingy and so yeah the presence
of Palpatine being fully resurrected
wasn't a part of that original draft
apparently so I get why it wasn't in the
last Jedi script that being said yeah
that would have been a better idea
uh-huh oh yeah Edwards and that's a
great point about the anticipation alone
because yeah that is true is like the
last Jedi for better or worse you know
does sort of stand on its own especially
with the amount of departure they wanted
to take I feel like I could have been a
good connective tissue and I think one
of my big complaints with the way rises
Skywalker especially handles the force
is it seems to be a solution for so many
things when it's required to for the
plot but not other things that's why
well yeah they could be yes I love that
quick-set bit that they brought up here
is I didn't even think about that when I
was watching the movie I've only seen it
one time in theaters but I imagine that
if I were to free watch it I would
probably go to that point especially
considering how insanely powerful ray is
in rise of Skywalker there yeah she
probably easily could have just lifted
them out of the quicksand yeah and with
enough force she was able to hold battle
with kylo Ren in that one scene like in
front of and that too which by the way
that was hysterical anyone on that ship
yeah just come out and take in a quick
shot gotta choke so true it was a common
complaint
yeah blaster dude shoot is so funny the
way they handled an entire season
there's just great comedy hilarious yeah
well in the end the Threepio bid is
something that I thought of from the
very first trailer I was like yeah I
know that we have been along with this
ensemble but I feel like Threepio has
much closer friends than any of the
notebook it said maybe next up oh yeah
yeah yeah and then the whole thing about
deleting through the message which I
don't think any Threepio would do I
don't think you would do that that's
such a solid because that is something
that has crossed my mind about the force
ghost especially in this one in last
Jedi with Yoda send that thing on fire
and then this one with Luke Luke and
catching the lightsaber yeah lifting the
x-wing quit early these worst ghosts
have the Patrick Swayze abilities of a
ghost so why aren't all them just
helping out and coming into battle yeah
that's a great point
that's not established in the original
trilogy so in this new trilogy they're
showing these force ghosts can do all
these things and I do think in terms of
cameo because some Star Wars fans loved
like hearing the voices of ahsoka katana
characters in the Clone Wars or rebels
because it's officially Canada and
definitely tied in with the movies it
would have been so much cooler to see
all them appear and just generally
speaking I would have been down for that
would I have wanted them all to fight
Palpatine no no they just kind of stood
in a circle around as Rey does it but
they could have that's the point of this
how it should have ended video is why
wasn't that even brought up at all like
it was a possibility that I don't think
the movie was even aware of a that's why
I mean I think the rules are not really
well defined in this movie in terms of
force ghosts the force in general and I
think how it should have ended is a
great job at poking fun at these holes
yeah cuz it really does seem like over
the course of at least the new movies
that the force does become this nebulous
thing as soon as there's a challenge
that seems like it could be met with the
force it seems like they write it in
that way but I haven't gotten the
complete sense that anybody who's
written these new ones has like a set of
you know just like a page of like yours
basic abilities here the the theories of
how this ought to work and take that and
go with it
yeah the force is
weird it's a weird fix-all and then yeah
to introduce so many cool ideas in the
rise of Skywalker having that thing
where they're able to like to grab the
lightsabers when they're mentally
connected or whatever
let me introduce these things that are
cool and then they add don't quite use
them when they move is fun it's a great
time watching it if you're not that
angry about everything happening alright
guys what do you think of this how it
should have ended which points do you
most agree with them on I'll leave a
comment down below subscribe to the reel
rejects and click that notification bell
to get accepted into the reject nice
[ __ ] Hey last but not least we'll send
this with a michael b omni media how you
doing there Michael guys I wanted to
tell you to subscribe to on me medias
Channel I'm number one it's Omni media
right he just has one name but it's
stylized with a 1 and I confusing it's
not gonna catch on um one media that's
our most Fortson ager never achieve fame
too complicated of a name go check out
his youtube channel he is covering so
much stuff right now
and he's doing reactions for so many TV
shows if you're DC fan he's covering a
lot of those DC TV shows Doctor Who so
many different things and he is killing
it in the game he's almost a two
thousand subscribers he's like he was a
slow-growth and then lately he's just
been blowing up and popping off make
sure to check out his channel as soon as
you can because he's just a very sweet
gentleman who loves to send me very long
messages on patreon and if I don't get
back to him within a day he sends me
another extended monologue but due to
his impatience he's a really agitated
obsessive rage-filled individual mm-hmm
and I'm a people pleaser so it really
works on my guilt sounds like a great
relationship dynamic
so Mykleby you're making it happen buddy
you're killing it on YouTube and you're
manipulating me and to responding faster
I love you I love you too keep it up you
know get him into place shape him in
your image because there's nothing
better than peace okay we can we can as
we're gone yeah